我给大家举几个例子啊。
比如说。
像美国喜剧中心出的那个很多片儿，喜剧片，他因为都是强设定，就很典型。我给大家看过的定制伴郎，那不就是吗？你那个动作谁能认可啊，花钱雇个人来演自己的好朋友，给自己当伴郎，谁能认可？
对吧？
认可不了。
但是呢观众看你那怂样。
看你呢哎呀打个电话给给同学，让别人来参加你的婚礼，同学都把你给忘了，还有的同学以为你死了。
对吧这个这个这个。
就想想，哎呀，你确实也是对吧？
还有那个那个那个。
同样是凯文哈特主演的另外一个电影叫御前教育。
就一个。
华尔街精英。
看起来的精英啊，但其实傻了吧唧的。
那个那个那个因为经济犯罪要入狱。
要入狱了。
然后呢，他因为从小就是。
养尊处优啊。
妥妥的富二代的。
他对监狱的认知啊，他对美国监狱的认知啊跟咱们差不多，跟咱们这些不可能接触到美国监狱的人一样。对美国监狱的认知就是。
各种大肌肉男对吧？黑人一帮白人变态一帮，然后那个T back嘛，对吧？还有那个墨西哥人一帮，对吧？全部剃着光头，满身纹身。然后进去之后不光要揍你，让你给他刷马桶，而且你洗澡的时候，你可别减肥皂，对吧？
很危险的，就是咱们对监狱的认知也是这样嘛，他对监狱的认知也是也是这样。
然后呢。
他因为经济犯罪要要入狱嘛。
有个期限，什么时候判判他什么时候要开始服刑，还有一个月。
然后他就去他经常修车的一个。
修车店开修车店呢是个小黑人。
凯威哈特。
哈特你知道那个风格啊，他叨逼叨叨逼叨的，然后说话说很多脏话，然后他就认为这个人肯定经过监狱，然后就花很多钱雇这个人。
培训自己监狱生存技巧。
凯文哈特。
其实也是个乖宝宝，没进过监狱，但是呢看在钱的份儿上就赶紧查攻略啊，到时候打听啊，就是开始训练他如何在监狱能活下去，怎么样分清各种帮派，怎么样在监狱里耍狠，怎么样说脏话，对吧？甚至怎么样打架，就开始训练他，这就是一听就是知道是个喜剧片。
为啥？就这动作你不认可的呀？你如果被判刑了，还有一个月进监狱，你会做这个事吗？不可能做这个事儿的呀，对吧？这是一个不合理的动作。
不合理的动作。
所以。
这就是动作的设定方式，对吧？以前教育包括那个嘛。
我们说二次动作那里我给大家举个例子，二次动作很典型的那个。
录取通知。
一帮高中小孩，高三小孩毕业之后没考上大学，怕父母责怪，说自己咋啥玩意儿考不上呢？他们几个人不是造了一个假大学吗？
这个这个这定了几个大牌子租一个破厂房，然后说这就是什吧？
那个那个那个什么什么商学院嘛，就就就假装是个大学嘛，这个动作不也不合理吗？
完全不合理，对吧？完全不合理。
但是也认可了。
因为正常来说，你怎么可能去造一个假的大学？
正常是我的话，我就造一个。
上海交大的录取通知书，然后我妈每次来上海看我，我就我就到那个学校里面待着，然后从那个学校走出来迎接她不就完了吗？你干我自己建一个大学，对不对？你假算在里边上学，谁知道啊，四年以后再去办一个毕业证，谁知道你这应该。
跟你爸说，哎，爸，我考上北大了是吧？然后你爸把你送到北大没问题的呀，送到北大，然后接新生的，然后你就跟着人家一块进去。四年以后，等你爸来接你的时候，你再。
你再去印一个就教害小朋友的这这一段，好像是吧？我的意思就是那才是相对合理的一个选择。你如果真的过不去这一关的话，对吧？如果你爸妈非要逼你考上大学，你过不去这一关的话，你也不应该造一个大学呀，那要成本太高了，对吧？成本和收益不成。
不成正比呀。
所以说这也是从动作角度从动作角度。然后我们说故事要素。
故事要素人物下面是事件，对吧？
世件。
我们说事件这里。
我其实课上讲过。
就是怎么样去从事件角度，从结构角度。
从结构角度。
因为事件啊是你这个故事的肚子。
你怎么样从事件角度，从结构角度。
来选择一个。
有喜剧操作空间的。
事儿呢。
我看上讲过。
我说小人物遇大事，大人物遇小事。
这种就很容易做出喜剧。
小人物出大事儿，大人物遇小事。
就是关于大小人物这个。
对吧。
这一条大家也可以走这条路，很容易做喜剧。
很容易做戏剧。
当然了，事件也有很多其他的，比如说常用的还有巧合。
一个含有巧合元素的事件。
还有巧合元素的事件。
往往也是具有喜剧属性的呀。
早期的喜剧，你看很有很多用长长得一模一样这个梗。
大家回忆一下，有很多电影用谁跟谁长得一模一样。这个梗。
两个人就是长得一样呀。
那个那个。
周星驰都用过。
周星驰跟那个梅艳芳，反正是人家的老公是一个大富豪。
他跟他长得一模一样。
长得一模一样。
巧合。
或者是。
或者是最后发现是双胞胎。
也有很多吧。
早年有很多人用双胞胎圆梗，就圆到最后啊，这俩人其实是双胞胎，其实一直是两个人。遇到这种片，我们就一直知道这种片呢基本上因为我们经常审剧本嘛，这种片呢我们就不给pass，不给pass卡了，直接就就就就就打回去了，因为这个梗太老了。
太老了，双胞胎梗对吧？这都属于巧合。
所以你看啊从事件这里从结构角度，大人易小事儿，小人物出大事儿，巧合都是经常用的。但其实更多的啊喜剧的本质。
喜剧的本质用的更多的其实是困境。
其实是困境。
书有点乱，大家自己整理吧啊，用的更多的是困境。啥叫困境？
就是不是不是嘛。
大人务遇小事，小人务出大事，本质上都是不是呀，本质上都是一个困境呀，一个困境，一个困局，一个不是。
难受。
你才能造成俯视吗？才能造成。
观众的爽感吗？快感吗？
困境不是巧合都是这种。比如说。
羞羞的铁拳。
羞羞的铁拳，男女互换身份，一个大老爷们的灵魂穿到一个女的身体里，他自然也不是嘛。
他能做出来的那些事儿，你你也能想想到一个女的女人的灵魂，娇弱的女人灵魂穿越到一个男的拳击手的身体里，她自然也打不了拳了嘛。
他自然是小拳拳捶你胸口嘛，对吧？本来要去参加比赛，他上去小拳拳捶你胸口。
那肯定不是嘛，不是困境。
所以说从事件角度。
我们大家记住这个原则。
主要是寻找困境，制造不适。
简单的方式呢就有大小人物巧合这种你自己去琢磨琢磨，找找参考片好吧。然后我们说故事要素除了人物和事件以外。
还有个东西叫主题。
我们说主题。
是制造喜剧的元素之一吗？
就说你的主题可以是喜剧吗？
也可以。
那就是其实啊就是我们经常说的。
黑色幽默。
黑色幽猛。
就是你这个主题啊。
它是喜剧主题，它是个黑色幽默的主题。我们说主题那里我其实讲过说这个价值观啊一定要倍儿正。
毫无争议的那种政放之四海皆政。
对吧什么那个那个那个善恶的那种，或者是什么救赎的，或者是什么人要勤奋的，天道酬勤的对吧？这个这个这个呃爱大于恨，对吧？什么什么这种。
关爱他人这种。
全是这种主主题。本来我那节课课上是这么讲的，但是在有些喜剧里面是可以有黑色幽默的。
它其实相当于是一种反价值，是一种对价值的信谑。
啥叫黑色幽默啊？我先这里我先给大家解释一下这个名词，啥叫黑色幽默？黑色本来就是指死亡。
死亡是最黑色的东西嘛，或者是说这个。
广义的死亡对吧？广泛意义上的一个死亡，对死亡的一种信誉。
比如说。
我们字面意义上的一解死亡。
有个人来杀你，掏出刀，白刀子进，红刀子出，扑哧给了你一刀。
把你杀死了。
然后你临死之前说，哇，这个刀好快啊，把淘宝链接发给我，这就是一场对死亡的信谑，这就是标准的黑色幽默。
黑色幽默是吧？问人家要淘宝链接。
这就是标准黑色幽默。
我给大家举个例子吧啊，因为黑色幽默的很多片子呢过不了审。
我给大家举个例子，大家去可以去看一下。比如说。
有个电影叫斯大林之死。
自己去看吧。
或者是说像那个。
呃，独裁者。
独裁者。
那种都属于。
黑色幽默的片子。
他的主题上。
就首先。
也是有喜剧基因的。还有一个电影嗯呃德国的。
讲的是。
希特勒复活了，对吧？
他重新。
一步一步。
掌控这个国家。
对吧。
而且。
搞得还不错，像这种主题呢也属于黑色幽默。
黑色用过。
他就在主题角度。
就已经。
很戏谑了。
很反价值也是有的。而且大家发现发没发现一个问题。
你看啊。
人物事件主题。
我前面讲过，我说喜剧和悲剧是有歧视链的。
对吧悲剧和正剧肯定是歧视喜剧的。
喜剧内部也有70辆。
喜剧内部也有奇士雷啊，同学们。
主题喜剧的。
瞧不起事件喜剧的。
世界喜喜剧的瞧不起人物喜剧的。
你自己体会一下。
我也是个普通人，我我也会陷在这种歧视类里面就会觉得你在主题上玩喜剧更高级。我事件和人物看起来很正常，对吧？
一本正经的在讲一个事儿，一本正经的讲讲人物，要塑造很正常的人物。但我的主题很黑色幽默，我感觉我挺高级。
然后呢，有的人就在世界上喜剧，就是我这个事儿嘛在结构上玩了一个巧合，我有一个精心的设计和布局。
然后呢，我我有大荣誉小事或者小荣物出大事，或者是我制造了一个很好的困境。我这个喜剧呢，哎，你看看我这属于结构型喜剧啊，我这叫麻花喜剧，麻花喜剧全是这种开心麻花喜剧，全是这种事件喜剧。
事件喜剧。
然后呢，他会觉得呢他瞧不起身份喜剧。
就是。
乡村爱情吧，孙问喜剧的典型代表就是乡村爱情。
就所有的人都很奇怪。
但是事儿呢其实是没有。
没有结构上的太多。
突破了。
世界喜剧、麻花喜剧。
从体感上感觉啊体感上啊。
好像比人物喜剧。
高级人民给。
这就是喜剧内部的起始点。
喜剧内部的起始点就是主题喜剧，其实是世界喜剧，世界喜剧其实是人物喜剧。
大可不必。
我知道我也曾经说过啊，你在身人物身份上去做缺陷或者玩食尿癖。我们叫食尿癖喜剧嘛，其实是有点那个。
稍微有点low。
但是喜剧。
他用郭德纲老师的话说，本身最主要的目的是搞笑，或者是说先搞笑。郭德纲老师不是说嘛，你先搞笑嘛，其他你先别扯了，你如果连让人发笑都没做到，你还跟我扯什么那个那个价值啊，扯什么主题啊，扯什么那个那个关爱他人正能量。
对吧先搞笑，我我觉得这说的是很有道理的。作为一个喜剧，你你设计这个喜剧的时候，你不就是为了让大家笑一笑，轻松一下。所以你先搞笑，先搞笑再说。而且呀每个人对喜剧的理解，每个人的笑点是不一样的。
你搞一个主题喜剧，你拍一个斯大林死，很多人他看不懂的，他不会觉得好笑的呀。
所以说没有必要。
有歧视，没有必要严格的去分高高低。好吧，这里我就是给大家简单说一下这个。
只是跟大家说一下区别。
然后从估事要素的角度，在这个三这三个方面。
都可以做喜剧。现在大家明白了是吧？明白。
那么在我们的每一具体的每一场戏中，具体的每一个节拍中，或者是具体这个戏的呈现形式上，我们怎么去搞喜剧呢？
也是有办法的，就是我们说的呃喜剧元素嘛。
关于具体的一些喜剧元素怎么搞嘞？
有办法常用的啊，比如说。
比如说反转。
反转我们说在喜剧中是很常用的一种手法吧。
让你想不到给你个意外，哎，这一反转，这就属于。
喜剧元素。
也讲一个课上的例子吧。
我讲过一个例子。
嗯，有个美剧叫how爱没to mother，老爸老妈。
浪漫史。
里面有个角色呢，巴你。
生长在单亲家庭。
他妈妈呢一个人把他养大，他不知道自己的父亲是谁。
他还有个哥哥是个黑人，就是他妈呢年轻的时候挺活泼的，生了两个儿子，一个黑人，一个白人。然后呢呃都没有爸法。
然后突然有一天。
这俩兄弟都长大了，三十几岁了。
收拾家里旧物的时候，发现一个信封。
寄给某个人，然后信封里面呢。
是他和哥哥的合照，就小时候两个人的照片，照片背后写着，这是你儿子。
然后他们就是获得了。
找自己父亲的一个线索。然后我们这个barney呢是我们这个戏的男主角之一。
他因为从小缺少父爱，搞得对爱情啊什么的也没有信心。
很怪异的一个性格。
他呢坚持想去找他爸爸。
他哥哥呢是一个理性人。
嗯。
就就就不是很赞同，但也陪着弟弟去找他。
结果是什么呢？
他们去找到了这个地址，敲开了这个门。
开门的是一个黑人老头。
这首先是第一个反转。
就是他不是把你的爸爸。
是个黑人老头。
然后呢。
我们的这个主角，我们的巴黎。
冲上去抱着这个黑人老头。
深情的喊了一声爸爸。
他甚至开始发掘自己的黑人基因，说自己很有音乐天赋，很有运动天赋，然后就开始现场唱各种蓝调唱不录，然后现场跳舞，现场玩乐器，就是想证明他就是个黑人。
这就是反转。
首先那个人很明显，他不是你爸爸，他是你哥哥的父亲，对吧？就说明他跟他哥哥那肯定不是同一个爸爸嘛。
是他哥哥父亲。
但是呢我们的8年。
反转。
这个我在课上讲过，为什么讲过这这个例子为什么非常好呢？首先它具备反转要素，让你完全想不到。
第二呢。
标准了喜剧和悲剧。
是阴阳两极。
的完美体现。
我说喜剧和悲剧其实是不分家的。看这段的时候，我开始是在笑的，因为他在拼命的跟那个黑人显摆他的。
运动基因。
音乐基因的时候，你会觉得把你。
对吧很搞笑，一个白人非得说自己是黑人，非得认那个。
黑人老头当自己的爸爸很搞笑。
但是呢。
其实你也很想哭。
因为。
巴你太想要一个父亲了。
他缺少父爱，从小没有见过父亲，没有父爱。
他在这一刻，他鼓起勇气，经过那么激烈的思想斗争。
不远千里开车过去。
敲开了这个门。
他其实内心是付出了非常非常多的。
挣扎。
鼓足了非常大的勇气的。
所以在门开的那一刻。
开门的虽然是一个黑人老头儿。
但是其实在那一刻。
巴尔尼已经找到父亲了。
他的这个旅程。
他敲开了这个门，他敢面对这一切，他已经找到父亲了。所以。
他找到的不是那个黑人的老头，他找到的是自己心中的父亲。
他想要一个父亲，这个情感是大于具体谁是我父亲呢？
这不就是小蝌蚪找妈妈吗？
谁是我妈妈真的那么重要？
我只要。
认可自己。
我只要找到自己。
我只要找到爱。
所以说。
这个反转。
是我经常举例的。
就是因为。
写的非常好。
这就是戏剧。
这就是给你。
那还有具体反转。
都有哪些方法怎么去搞？
大家自己去看前面的课。
去找到反转那一刻，自己去看，好吧。
第二。
比如还有什么呢？
嗯，排比。
海笔也是喜常用的喜剧元素呀。
啊，大家去回忆一下很多的，比如说啊。
这个这个。
课堂上我们说一个调皮捣蛋的差班的课堂，然后镜头装在轨道上，然后摇着往后往后推。每一个同学都在干什么？
这就是排比。
典型的排比。
对吧有的在那打游戏，有的在那化妆，有的在那这个偷看小儿书。有的呢男女朋友高三课堂在那亲嘴。
它就是一个排比结构。而且呢你去看它的这种节奏，它永远是。
一个比一个过分。
一般是12三转。
第一个有点过分，第二个更过分。第三个再过分，第四个反转。
反转。
你去看这种排比节构，很多的。
还有两个排名。
嗯，讲个举个例子啊，两个排比的情况非常非常多啊，也非常非常多，就是做对比嘛。
比如说。
老有记。
老友记里面啊老友记是经典喜剧啊，老友记里面ross和racachel男女主角。
谈恋爱了。
第一次亲嘴。
清完之后呢。
那肯定是回去之后要跟好朋友们分享嘛，女方跟自己闺蜜分享说啊，你们知道吗？我跟ross接吻了，然后啊闺蜜都炸窝了，你知道吗？真的吗？真的吗？哎，快点详细说说，然后拿爆米花拿水拿来抱枕，一群人在沙发边上围坐一圈，然后开始问各种细节。
对吧谁先亲的谁呀，谁主动的呀，他手放在你腰上还是放在哪儿啊，那个就各种聊，对吧？你们俩怎么终于突破这层窗户纸了呀，天堂都特别快，就叨叨叨叨叨叨，就是先拍女方这面。
从宣布这个消息。
这这一场戏，然后镜头马上切到男生宿舍。
男主角推门进去，告诉自己的另外两个。
哥们儿。
我跟瑞秀亲嘴了。
然后一个人问。
伸舌头了吗？啊，伸了。
另外一个人说牛逼结束了。
结束了啥意思呢？就是女方啊女女生啊就是八卦体制嘛，什么都要问清楚，男的呢就很直接，对吧？亲嘴是一种吃没伸舌头性质不一样啊，是吧？问清楚。
就行了。
干净简练，这种属于两个排比，或者说是要对比对吧？对比也是。
很容易做笑点。
做喜剧元素的地方。然后还有比如说。
我们说叫结构经典。
结构经典也是很容易做喜剧元素的呀。我们说结构经典的类型，比如说。
麻花也有很多。
周星驰也有很多。
就是颠覆你一个。
传统认知嘛经典嘛，比如说一个。
很好色的唐僧。
很能叨叨的唐僧，对吧？那个那个周星驰那个大话西游，很能叨叨的唐僧不就是颠覆你对经典的一个认知嘛，对吧？然后桃园三结义对吧？桃园三结义这个刘关张。
这个在这儿结为兄弟，然后供着一个关公，供着一个关公，这不是结构经典嘛？是吧？就是经典结构类的也是非常非常多的一个类型。你们大家自己去看啊，一个什么三国呀、西游记呀或者是经典影视作品里面的。
人物呀。
在各种喜剧片里面也是被解构的，不要不要。
你们自己去研究吧，这个难度不大啊这个难度不大，你们自己去研究吧。
我就不过多举例子了。然后。
还有啊比较重要的比较重要的呃，值得一讲的其实是台词。
哎，这个就对吧？是每一个喜剧片里面必须要用的必须要用的。你作为一个喜剧片，你怎么也得有喜剧台词嘛？
怎么也得有喜剧台词。
所以说。
这个是很重要的。当然我在讲台词那节课里面啊，我其实说过很多台词是跟着情境来的呀。
你的情境好，你的台词才牛逼呀。
对不对？
你的情境好，台词才牛逼啊。我们说比如说。
赵本山老师的那个那个小品礼要啥自行车？
要啥自行车本身不是一个不是一句特别搞笑的话，对吧？不是搞笑的台词。但是他在这个情境里面，哎，它就可以成为。
经典的喜剧台词，所以说台词啊有很多是跟着情景来的。
很多根据情境来的。
那样的台词呢也也更能让你记得住更有趣。
但是那个呢得得根据具体情景，得是你前面做的很好，你才能加上配合这些的优秀台词，对吧？配你的人物有一个很不合理的那个设定，有个很棒的标签。那么比如说那个那个那个那个。
肖dom对吧？是个很标签化的人物嘛，那他有自己的符合人设的台词，或者符合他行为方式的台词，大家能记得住。
那是一种情况。那种情况呢其实是考验的是你前面的功力。
我们单独来讲一下什么呢？就是你平地抠饼的时候，就是说情境一般，你就是要加上搞笑的台词，怎么加，这其实叫幽默。
这其实就叫幽默。
就是呃情境没啥，或者是目前的人设很一般。但是呢你就想说出有趣的台词，比如说那个老友记里面的。
canderer。
老友记里面几个男主角。
那个jo易和rose都是有自己明显的。
人设特点，也如说他们从人物上其实就有笑点了。但是签在这呢人设就相对就故意设的很平，但是他语言很幽默。也就说这个角色很幽默，他的台词呢也会很有趣，对吧？像这种情况呢我们也是会经常遇到的，就是你这个角色是正常角色。
遇到正常事儿，但是我就想让他说话搞笑。
也是可以做的，这个就有点像那个了。
其实有点像相声啊。
或者是脱口秀那种感觉的底子了。
我也可以给大家简单讲一些方法吧。好吧，因为其实关于喜剧啊，完全可以开一个月的课。
对吧然后关于喜剧台词怎么创造，其实就是怎么讲笑话。我我再次强调啊，喜剧台词分两种，一种是根据你的情境和设定来的。
要啥自行车，对吧？这种。
他是考验的是你前面的功力。
然后第二种才是哎状况平平，人物平凡，我就是要写出幽默的台词那种呢其实考验的是你写脱口秀或者写相声的能力，我也可以给大家讲一讲。
但是呢那个也是一个庞杂的系统，脱口秀，那又是一个庞杂的系统。我给大家简单讲几个方法吧。好吧，简单讲几个方法。比如说我们说脱口秀里面。
他最重要的。
最重要的理念啊其实叫制造预期，打破预期嘛，也就是一个叫。
预期。
破除。
对吧。
预期破除呢其实不就是让你想不到吗。
让你想不到啊，也有两种方法，一种是我生破破你的预期。另外一种呢是我先引导你，我给你下一个套，下一个扣，然后再破除你的预期。所以它在这个预期破除这里，它有一种说法叫制造预期打破预期。当然了，在实际的台词当中。
有时候也不需要制造预期。
你就生破也可以。比如说啊。
比如说思维错位类错位类的台词。
错位类的台词。
这里都需要举例子，大家才能听得懂啊。
比如说啊。
女生宿舍女生宿舍里，然后呢一个。
女孩儿。
急匆匆跑回来说，我刚才在楼下便利店买爆米花，一个色狼想要从性骚扰我。然后我出来之后呢，他还跟踪我吓死我了，我跟村回来了，我差点让人强奸了。
然后他的室友说。
楼下便利店还开着呢。
还有爆米花啊，什么味儿的？
对吧。
这个呢就是一段搞笑台词。
就是错位。
因为。
你在描述你的悲惨经历，有色狼尾随你，骚扰你，大家全都不关心。大家关心的是你买的爆米花多少钱呃，什么味儿？
便利店还有吗？我也要下去买，这就是标准的错位。
其实错位本质上啊也是制造预期，打破预期。你在描述这件事情的时候，你制造的预期，这是大家关心什么色狼，对吧？这个大单我我们报警吧，我只制造这个预期，那么打破预期就是这就是一种方法，叫思维错位的一种方法。还有比如说从台词的角度啊。
重复。
有时候也是一种。
很好的方法。
比如说。
老有纪理，还说老有纪理。
那个有一对男女。
谈恋爱了。
就主角中有一对男女谈恋爱，唯一的知情人是。
交椅。
交易是知情人，然后那个呢其他人就来审问他。
审问他说就大家做好准备，就他是唯一的知情人来审问他这个这个这个那俩人到底什么情况，然后就开始连珠不号的问问题，说他们俩到底什么时候。
呃，搞在一块了。
就会说I don't know,我不知道。然后呢。
嗯，谁先追的谁？
我不知道。
那个他们俩是玩真的，还是就是约炮了？
我不知。
然后。
那个那个那个反正问了一连串的问题。
交易权势我不责。
就有点像张飞的，俺也一样，明白吧？就人家不管说什么，他都是俺也一样。
交易是我不知道，他是真的不知道，而且他最后也有反转说，那你他妈到底知道点什么呢？嗯，那次你不在家，他们在你床上打了一炮，这个是大家知道的，知道吧？这就是反转就是在重复。
重复也是就重复台词也是一种。
很有用的这个这个方式。
在那个。
美式脱口秀里面，他们还有一种叫法叫ca back。其实call back和。
重复啊不完全一样。
topback更像是你前面点过这句词，你最后再用上合题，你懂我意思吧？就我这句话，你看你前面没笑，我再用一次的时候，你就笑了，我终于用上了，而且这次用对了。
其实它跟重复呢有点像，就是同一句台词重复，这叫重复的力量，重复台词是很有力量的，也是一种常用的方式。好吧，在台词这里啊，我这里讲的都是台词啊，与台词有关的方式啊。
还有比如说。
另。
类比或者比喻啊。
也是一种常用的台词方法。
给家讲个例子啊。
举个例子。
哎呀一下什么想例子是最累的一件事儿，你知道吧？得从你看过剧的剧里面，电影里面找出相关的正好对应的例子。
哎咱就说咱讲的课吧，我之前给大家讲电视剧和电影的区别的时候。
我说我说电视剧是。
我说电视剧是谈恋爱。
电影是是史嫖娼，很多人不就笑了吗？
这就是比喻的力量。
而且比喻完了之后，比喻这个后劲儿也很大。我说电视剧是谈恋爱的一种体验，所以电影是嫖娼的一种体验。然后在后面讲电影更讲究服务，讲究满意度，讲究时长乱七八糟的时候，你们都在笑，为什么呢？就是因为这个比喻。
带来这种力量，对吧？或者是说叫。
类比就两个差不多的事情。
如果一类比。
就会很好笑。
所以咱就不用找影视剧里面的例子了啊。
我还可以给大家讲一个例子啊。
就是。
嗯，我跟我一个同事之间的例子。
说这个不知道会不会引战，没事啊，我们纯从我们纯是从台词的角度。
去理解这个问题啊，就理解泪比类的台词。为什么有时候他是幽默的？
我一个同事。
是一个北京大姐。
有一次他说了一段很经典的一段话，我给大家学一下啊，学一下大概的内容你就知道。
这个北京大姐就跟我说，她说。
小桃啊。
我可是不是一个地域歧视的人。
我虽然是土生土长的北京人，但我这个人真不地域歧视。我有很多外地人的朋友呀，对吧？
我讨厌的是哪种呢？讨厌的是那种来了北京霍霍我们北京的人。
对吧没有素质，不讲卫生，不讲文明，就往大城市里扎。
霍霍我们北京这种人我是讨厌的，但真正来建设我们北京的外地人呢。
讲文明讲礼貌又来建设首都的人，我们当然欢迎啊。
对吧只不过我们小时候啊，我们那个北京啊。
山清水秀，小河流水。
哎。
马路上也不堵车对吧？那样的北京呢再也回不去了。
就我这个大姐呢就跟我说了这么一段话。
这段话呢。
从字面上理解其实没毛病，他说的没毛病。
但是呢。
有些玻璃心的人呢，比如说这个这个这个很多人对地欲其士这个事儿很上心嘛。如果上心的话，这个话听着就不舒服了。
对吧。
我当时呢反正也。
我主要是为了搞笑。
然后我就。
我就用类比台词跟大家对话。然后说大姐，您说的对，我同意是吧？我说哎大姐。
你这双眼皮是哪年拉的？
对吧然后大姐说啊，对吧？前些年拉的呀，好看吗？
我说大姐啊，我觉得您这个双眼皮啊。
挺好看。
我呢？
真不是一个歧视拉双眼皮的人。
是吧。
我真不歧视。
你拿了双眼皮之后。
如果漂亮。
增加了整体双眼皮人的颜值。
我很欢迎啊。
对吧我讨厌的是那种什么人呢？
就长得丑，还要拉去拉个双眼皮儿。
拿着也不好看。
拉低了我们整个双眼皮人的颜值，搅乱了我们双眼皮人的这个市场，对吧？有些人呢拉了一个假双眼皮。
就就就感觉自己好看。有些人呢贴了个双眼皮，贴办一个暂住证是吧？这个也在这儿混成双眼皮。
是这些人呢把整体颜值给搞坏。
如果是真要是，拿完之后变漂亮。
我们当然接受当然欢迎。
只不过我们以前啊。
那个没有整容，没有拉双眼皮的，大家都是自然美的那个年代呀。
哎，再也回不去了。
然后这段话一说呢，就给大姐气够呛，你知道吗？但是呢这就是。
一段类比类的台词。
类比类的台词就啥意思呢？就是用另外一种比喻来解析刚才的那个理论。
要么解析的更明确了，让要么让你看清楚里面荒诞的本质，对吧？这就是类比和比喻类的台词。
还有常见的，比如说台词类的就是增加流行元素。
这个很容易理解吧。
增加流行元素啊，很容易理解吧。你在你的台词里面适当增加流行语，哎，也是可以让你的台词更俏皮更搞笑。
所以简单说这几个方面，好吧，简单说这几个方面，这就是关于台词，我们怎么样去增加一些所谓的喜剧元素。
这节课呢就是从这些方面简单给大家说一下，浅谈啊浅谈一下喜剧，浅谈一下戏剧。
欠他一下戏曲。
最后再说一下我们这个喜剧啊。
说一下，我在工作中常遇到一个问题啊，就关于无厘头。
关于无厘头喜剧，因为。
喜剧啊。
也是有类别的。
啊，就分啥类别啊，你知道我们在这个收片的时候啊，我们在收片或者收剧本的时候，我们给喜剧就分两类。
一种叫东北喜剧，另外一种叫其他喜剧，或者是一种叫东北喜剧。除了东北喜剧以外，全部叫南派喜剧。
就南方喜剧就分这两种。
南方喜剧呢其实就是以港台的那种气质为主。
但是。
东北喜剧绝对占主流。
东北人扛起了中国喜剧的大半江山。
这个你是种族优势啊，种族优势这这个这个确实是有喜剧潜伏，你不服不行。而且呢人家不光有喜剧潜赋，人家还有长相上的优势。
西东北人的个儿高呀，个儿高脑袋小，脸小，五官的一体，这不天生的上镜的那啥嘛？对不对啊？所以他们又有喜剧天赋，所以从喜剧演员的角度肯定扛起大半江山，从演员的角度都扛半半壁江山，更不用说从喜剧演员的角度了。
所以我们收片的时候啊，我们谈到喜剧真的就两种，一种叫东北喜剧，另外一种叫其他喜剧。
而且东北喜剧数量还比其他喜剧多，我不是自卖自夸啊，我不是东北人啊，同学们很多很多同学以为我是东北人，很多有同学以为我是东北人，我不是啊，我是山东人。
山东人啊，这个这个但是我就说这个意思，就是东北喜剧确实是扛起了半壁江山。但是现在还有一种那那个有就是以前有一种喜剧叫无厘头喜剧。我在这里简单给大家说一下，因为我在工作里面碰到了，我不是说咱们实战课，我碰到啥就跟大家说啥嘛，碰到这个问题，那肯定是一个常见问题，就还现在还有很多人在写无厘头喜剧。
在写无厘头喜剧。其实啊无厘头喜剧。
已经随着星爷的淡出，以这种品类已经。
绝种了。
已经没有了，你不要再写了。
啥叫无厘头喜剧？我们先从定义上理解，无厘头啊就是粤语没来头。
没缘由，没理由，没道理，它的核心就是没有逻辑，明白吗？它的核心就是没有逻辑。我们说啊，你看啊我们的人物在制造俯饰，制造所谓的不合理的时候，但是逻辑还是要的呀。就是他这个不合理，虽然也让你会觉得哎呀这个角色不合理，真好笑，真傻逼，但是他还是有一根逻辑线在牵着的。
不会完全跳脱的，但是无厘头人家明讲的就是没逻辑，没理由呀。
就是没逻辑，这种喜剧就是随着星爷的出现而出现。随着星爷的淡出而淡出大。
只有他能驾驭。
你驾驭不了。
你想啊。
来。
在星爷的电影里，星爷去做一个大少爷，有的是钱，对吧？去全城最好的一个妓院。
去消费。然后进去之后，苑琼丹是老鸨子啊就出来了。然后星爷一把钱撒下，给我找你们镇店的最好的姑娘出来。然后愿琼丹拿着一把钱开心心子了，对吧？放心吧，大少爷来吧，这个这个这个呃春风夏花这个秋秋菊冬梅。
出来见客啦，然后出来三四个老太婆。
四个老太婆要多丑有多丑。
这就是标准的无厘头呀，他没有逻辑呀。
一个全城最好的妓院花那么多钱。
上来四个老太婆。
有逻辑吗？这个人是要坑星爷吗？还是说星爷批好特别呢？还是说这个县里就没有美女呢，没有逻辑，没有道理，你不用去深究这个逻辑。
你就看到星爷，你开心就可以了。
开心。
星爷就喜欢给你搞一个大叔挖鼻孔，然后说她是全程第一美女。
这就叫无厘头，就他能驾驭，你是驾驭不了的。
懂了？所以我提出这个意思就是啥呢？咱们同学不要给我写无厘头戏剧。
不要觉得这就是笑点。
你知道吗？不要觉得这是笑点，这不是。
你如果写这个没有星爷来演的话，那所有人就会觉得。
这是干嘛？
尴尬吗？
很尴尬的呀，对吧？
所以说无厘坨喜剧，我在这里。
单单独拿出来跟大家说一下，不要搞了，就放弃吧啊，最后总结一下。
也就是我之前。
最开始的时候说的。
所谓的喜剧。
和所谓的悲剧，所谓的这个阴阳两面和所谓的这个边界。
没有严格的。
编且也没有严格的高低贵贱，也没有严格的说什么怎么样搞笑就更好，怎么样搞笑就就就。
更高级。
没有。
而且但凡是喜剧。
我感觉总有人会被。
冒反岛。
总有人会被。
冒反倒。
你感觉你摧毁了一个没有价值的东西，那还只是。
你感觉。
那还只是你你的感觉呀。
总有人被。
冒犯党。
那至于这种冒犯。
是对是错呢？
我没有那么高的高度。
我就是一个编剧，是一个匠人，我教大家方法，大家自己去拿捏，好吧。
下课。
嗯。